slick roads could make for a dangerous
commute across the south this morning
sub-freezing temperatures froze
fountains from South Carolina to Texas
forecasters predict a coastal storm will
bring 1 to 3 inches of snow from North
Carolina to Georgia today Manuel
Bojorquez is in Brunswick Georgia where
they're under a state of emergency man
well good morning good morning Jeff
we're riding along with Georgia State
Troopers who are out in full force this
morning taking a look at the roads in
fact the person next to me captain Chris
Wright tells me that it's already become
a busy morning with reports of cars
spinning out along the interstate and
some highways parts of Brunswick have
essentially shut down already ahead of
the storm with schools either delaying
the start of classes or cancelling them
altogether
let's go ahead and give you a look right
now at our outside camera of i-95 of
course this is the main artery up and
down coastal Georgia and the big concern
here will be ice which were told has
already started to form on bridges and
overpasses let's talk about the numbers
nearly 250 crew members and 13 trucks
began treating roads last night with
sand and brine to keep the anticipated
ice from sticking but the headaches
headaches are not just here in Texas
slippery roads caused more than 30 car
accidents on Tuesday and with possible
snow later today Georgia officials are
hoping to keep coastal cities from
experiencing what happened in Atlanta in
2014 when a mere two inches of snow
caused gridlock that lasted more than 24
hours here in Brunswick city officials
are warning people that they will try to
treat as many roads as they can but they
don't have the resources to get to all
of them so the best advice here is if
you do not have to be out on the roads
simply stay home Nora
alright man well thank you so much